good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday they did I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters it's
actually the previous Friday but I'm
going on vacation so if anything
important has happened in the
intervening four days that I'm not
talking about it's because I don't know
let's get to the questions beard yeah
I'm kind of growing a beard I don't know
Sara wants me to what do you think why
do none of the main characters in your
books have siblings this is just my
little way of letting Hank know that in
my narrative imagination he does not
exist
you still have your holden caulfield
head you mean my people hunting hat yes
apples or oranges no I find it difficult
to compare them in your book Looking for
Alaska was Alaska's blank a blank or a
blank
I don't know also that's not really the
question for me the question is whether
we could live hopeful and thoughtful
lives in spite of ambiguity in spite of
the fact that important questions go
unanswered
hey when's the Paper Towns movie come
out there's an important question I will
not leave unanswered June 5th I just
watched like 10 minutes of the movie
that Jake Schreier showed me when I was
in Los Angeles I'm so excited Hank do
you have any productivity tips yeah so
first procrastinate for a while longer
longer wait until you feel like that
sour panic adrenaline in the back of
your throat and then go go go go go
that's a terrible productivity tip but
it's the only one I have how many licks
does it take to get to the center of a
Tootsie Pop between 150 and 500 and yes
there are studies about this links in
the doobly-doo favorite art assignment
video pretty fond of Christoph Neiman's
emotional furniture I also really
enjoyed the highlights video where I got
to make some prints with Sara links in
the doobly-doo favorite song by Taylor
Swift probably blank space or as Henry
calls it boys love torture hey are you
writing a new book
yeah I'm trying to but are you writing
really are you writing it yes but are
you writing a new book ah I'm just gonna
level with you that that's not helping
you have any advice for people who are
engaged to be married the main thing
that I'd say is that if you're doing it
right your marriage will be a lot longer
and more important than your wedding so
don't stress out too much about the
wedding do you listen to rap music
yeah actually not injustice introduced
me to a lot of artists I didn't
previously know about while I was on the
paper town set including Earl Sweatshirt
who I like a lot and then in turn I got
to introduce all of them did the
mountain goat so it was a good trade if
nerdfighteria became a sovereign nation
what would our national bird be
me question I'm gonna say owls because
they're renowned for their wisdom they
have like superpower hearing and they
can eat a mouse in a single bite plus
you know pet wigs so yeah I think our
national bird would be an owl but I'm
open to suggestions you get stopped at
the grocery store a lot more now that
Hank is so famous soand I was at a movie
theater I went up to the concessions and
the woman working there was so excited
and freaked out and she couldn't say
anything for a few seconds and then
finally she said oh man this is so wild
because I have a huge crush on your
brother
oh man you think it's hard for me Hank
imagine what it's like for Dave green do
you think all children should be
vaccinated no like for instance kids who
are immunosuppressed because if leukemia
shouldn't get some vaccines and there
are some vaccines that infants shouldn't
get that's precisely why I mean in
addition to one's own health and the
many pleasures of not getting measles
that the rest of us should get
vaccinated can you Anna gram
nerdfighters yes my favorite anagram for
nerdfighters is deft herrings although
I'm also quite fond of frightens read
favorite dinosaur Quetzalcoatlus
favorite apostle john curran toothbrush
color green see what i did there
and lastly Hank a nerdfighter asks what
should I name my pet rat as far as I can
tell there's really only one choice
Master Splinter Hank I'll see you on
Friday